PICKED UP BY KAKKO.
SHOT GOES OFF IN
QUICK REVERSE AND TRIES TO FLAG
THIS OVER THE PAD AND
RIELLY THROUGH THE TRAFFIC!
DEFLECTED ON THE W WROUGH THE BK
SIDE OF JACOB TROUBA BUT THIS I
STILL COUNT.
>> Gord: THAT T NET.
REALLY SWIFT, QUICK PASS KERFOO
SUPPORT SO IF SOMEONE GOT BEAT
OFF THE WALL THERE'S A PLAYER
POKE-CHECK THERE BY ERIES IN VE
YEARS AGO WHEN THEY CAME BACK
FROM 3-0 WILL TAKE PLACE AT
CECE
GOING ON HERE.
NOT ENOUGH SPEED TO BREATHE A
COUPLE OF
AND GET OUTSIDE OF THE DEFENCE.
HE'S Say: AND YOU DIDN'T, WHICH
RUSH CHANCE THE RANGERS HAVE
PLAY.
TWO EXTRA WHACKS AND
AND LIKE HE WAS
THE GUY IN THAT WORLD SERIES.
>> Gord: SO HE WARIES TO GAIN T
BUT AGAIN GETS S BY
SHOOTING IT OFF THE BY TROUBA AD
HE FINDS KAKKO.  STICK
THERE.
FROM STROME.
PLAY CONTINUES.  DOWN AS STROME.
BACK ACROSS PANARIN, THE
CENTRING PASS JUST MISSED!
>> Ray: THIS IS SCARBOROUGH
VERSUS MISSISSAUGA. .
TAKES THE PASS.
RITCHIE SHOOTS AND W W GO NOW I
THIRD PERIOD.
ONRE GETTING IT BUT THE
FACE-OFF WILL BE IN THE LEAF